welcome to the across the spoiliverse
podcast I'm your host David zazlov
joined by none other than Greg Alba as
always I'm in a bit of trouble this week
I've been there's been lots of box
office problems and we're gonna be
breaking it all down in this video Greg
how's it going it's going well David
much better than whatever you're
experiencing on your end I didn't know
you were British David it's good yeah
it's good to know you've Britt's taking
over our American companies our Warner
Brothers and all that everything's good
on your end friend yeah really good yeah
I'm actually feeling uh last week I was
a bit worn out and a bit exhausted
because that Bloody craving trailer but
this week I'm back I'm operating at 90
which is pretty good for me right now
and this is I promise you this is gonna
be our best episode ever every week I
promise you that but I mean it this time
yeah I think you're gonna kill it with
the conversations today we got a lot to
talk about people we got a lot Paul I
think we got to go into it so first
thing I'm gonna ask from the audience is
that you guys leave a like on this video
secondly here's the topics we're going
to go over there's chapters if you guys
want to hop around flash bombing again
Warner Brothers catastrophes Jonathan
Majors is in court Ben Affleck on
Deadpool three and a little tidbit from
James mangle where he did a variety
interview where he said some stuff that
we found very interesting but Paul I
think there's one thing we both want to
kick this off with right away
and it's a continuation a sequel from
this topic that never dies but the
movie's dying but it never dies for us
we talk about it almost every podcast
now the flash bombed yet again and it's
doing even worse what are the numbers
Paul
so the numbers right now and this is
according to coming soon.net The Flash
may end up losing Warner Brothers 200
million dollars at the end of its box
office run crazy so it grossed an
underwhelming 55 million dollars at the
domestic box office last week it's
second weekend yeah it's dropped down to
15.3 million which if we're going
percentage-wise that's 72 percent down
and that is basically a massive massive
drop the only film just to give you a
kind of hint at where that's at the only
film that's had a bigger drop than that
comic book movie wise is morbius so I
mean there's this weird thing with box
office in second weekend drops where
they make a big deal out of it and
they're like oh it dropped 50 now when
you filmed this really well that first
weekend and they're like it dropped 50
I'm like that that's quite a big you
know it's not they're still making a lot
of money even with half the revenue
coming in when you move when your movie
does terrible first weekend and it has a
72 percent drop that is absolutely
abysmal that is crazy like fair enough
if it was doing well and I had a had a
big drop you can understand it because
it's percentages but if it's doing bad
and it still has a massive drop boy
David zazlev I'm I'm in the hot seat
right now I'm in trouble I'm thinking
have I messed up yet
um so yeah I'm really really surprised
that it's been it's came out this badly
I think it's now in third place across
the spider-verse has rocketed back up to
number one obviously the last week
people have been whenever something like
this happens they're like it's a
superhero fatigue I think when across
the spider versus backup at number one
it kind of negates the point a bit how
are you feeling on it Greg I think it's
hilarious at this point Paul this is so
much it's sad it's sad really sad and
funny at the same time just because this
this journey with this movie of the
amount of rewrites and production delays
and
and how long how long guys like you and
I have been talking about this film and
a constant controversy surrounding its
star and what will this movie ultimately
amount to the build up the hype all this
and for it to this this should be I see
like it was it's been a crazy few weeks
going into the summer box office because
we had Guardians spider-verse
Transformers uh there's been so many
film I know there's one I'm missing
there's been so many films that have
been coming out and Flash had the
opportunity to not have to worry about
the next week because they didn't have
any competition releasing that could
really go against it
so it has this two-week window where it
should be just lighting the box office
on fire and it went down to third place
since fireworks going back up there's
something yeah buddy about what's
happening with this movie because of the
insane amount of hype around it and I
don't even know if it's going to do well
on video on demand because clearly the
word of mouth in this film it's just not
good it's fine it's I can't help but
kind of laugh at it because it is a sad
thing I mean okay I know I'm looking
like a total [__] right now it's kind
of funny at the same time come on guys
there's something humorous about just
how bad this film is taking after the
incredulous levels of hype this film's
had for so many years it's kind of it's
like when that there's that Meme of that
guy standing at the window laughing
looking in and it just says sickos on
his T-shirt I feel like it you're
kicking your man when he's down right
now you know I'm David saslab over here
I'm not having a good time
um yeah it's it's absolutely
unbelievable like because we thought you
know it will under like our expectations
were low but holy [__] to have it drop
down to this amount is absolutely
unbelievable
um as a massive DC fan you know I love
the Snyder stuff
um I'm really into that Matt Reeves
Batman love that joker the dceu you know
once they started steering it in their
own Justice League Direction I kind of
went off it a bit
um I I like Black Adam I will say that
Shazam I had fun with those films
um Wonder Woman obviously I enjoyed
Aquaman
but I I feel like there should be a full
reset of everything and this kind of
indicates to me that the audience has
completely abandoned these movies now
John campier he actually brought up a
really interesting point I'm someone
yeah who's been fully on the James Gunn
what are you doing you idiot you've
announced this universe doesn't matter
anymore and you're expecting the the
movies to make money now John campier
actually did a very good story where he
talked about this guy who uh a butcher
the story but I'll tell you there was
this guy who get went out one day put a
nut on the floor a squirrel came over
ate it and then coughed and then the
next day did it put a nut on the floor
peanut we'll call it squirrel came over
hey it coughed the next day put an
almond nut down the squirrel came over
ate it and coughed and then he went it
must be the almonds that making that's
making these squirrels cough like I said
completely butchered it
um but what that basically means is that
all of these movies to a bombing if you
look back at Shazam 2
base sorry if you look at everything
before James Gunn announced that these
movies were basically a part of a dead
Universe now they were still bombing
anyway so we're not really sure if we
can blame it on the almonds which are
James which is basically James Gunn just
announcing that this stuff doesn't
matter anymore and there is a high
possibility that this movie would have
bombed anyway
um I don't think that the situation with
James Gunn helped but when I've been
looking at the reasons for why the flash
bombed why the flash flopped there's so
many different things that you can point
your finger at and go well it flopped
because of Ezra or [__] because the
Batman and it's 30 years old or the VFX
were terrible and they leaked on Twitter
everywhere or they did screenings months
and months in advance
or you know there's so many different
reasons working against this film that I
don't think you can point to one and say
this is why it bombed it's just so many
different things that held it back
whereas when you compare it to what's
basically its Marvel counterpart which
is no way home
I've said you know this is DC trying to
do a no way home for their Studio when
you we look at the things that no way
home had in its favor it was a
Multiverse movie before the Multiverse
thing had been played out
you know you put you put your boy Tom
Holland against Ezra Miller in terms of
Star Quality the person leading the ship
I'm gonna say Tom Holland wins out every
time you put Michael Keaton against
um you know Andrew Garfield and Toby
Maguire
I feel like the though I love Batman
Returns I love Batman 89 I feel those
movies probably the Spider-Man ones
probably have a bit more love towards
them just because of you know that they
basically well Toby Maguire basically
revitalized a lot of the superhero stuff
along with the X-Men and blade now look
at the villains General Zod
okay look how villains in no way home
ton of them brilliant ones and then
lastly Sasha Kaye she's sort of your
side character who's the side character
in no way home Doctor Strange so even
Doctor Strange is like a massive
character at this point so you can kind
of see why no way home had a lot of
things working in its favor Kevin feige
didn't come out before and say this
movie might not matter
um you obviously didn't have all the
controversy surrounding the star the VFX
got finished I mean there was a ton of
leaks with no way home as well but they
seemed to Hype up the movie where's the
lexier it seemed to kind of be like oh
man this is this doesn't sound good so
yeah I think unfortunately the flash is
just a victim of a number of different
things and there's a lot of blame to go
around but when the box office is this
low for the opening weekend and then
this bad for the second one I'm at a
point now where I think
just get rid of the DC EU we've had our
fun it's good but I want DC to you know
I want them to keep making DC movies
um and I think if the franchise is in
this state you're going to have such a
difficulty investors they're not going
to want to put money into superhero
movies in general now I think I think
they're realizing it's quite a big risk
and it's not the the license to print
money that it used to be so investors
are going to be you know they're going
to be a bit more picky with their
superhero films and studios are as well
I think in general Hollywood's in quite
a bad state right now we're constantly
talking about bombs every week and
there's lots of projects that they've
spent lots of money on and they're not
all guaranteed hits anymore uh kovids
obviously the streaming there's lots of
different factors that have kind of
killed off people going to the theater
and the fact they're releasing a lot of
movies three weeks after they're in the
cinema now as well just so many
different reasons to get into but yeah I
feel feel like the DC brand at this
point if it's not a standalone film it's
bringing this baggage with it of the DC
EU and people not being interested in
that
yeah I think Warner we I mean this is we
should just talk about Warner Brothers
the current state of Warner Brothers and
we should talk about next topic yeah
that's I'm transitioning us smoothly
that's crazy that's crazy how
professional I am we should talk about
Warner Brothers and I wanted to touch a
couple of DC because I know we we've
talked about it before because you know
we have the we have Aquaman and Blue
Beetle coming out and it's going to be
crazy when they do and I think they're
going to try their best to distance I
think Aquaman is trapped because yeah
it's it's Aquaman 2. like there's no way
around it I think it's trapped to be
just associated with the DC EU which it
is uh but it needs to have that
Standalone effect and of course same
thing with Blue Beetle as much as you
try to say no no no we're we're reeling
in we're reeling in Jaime areas he's
part of the D he's the first DCU
character I think it's still going to be
negative if anything they should have
made that release after Aquaman then so
that way there's no confusion on that if
you really want to like pitch that
narrative to the audience so they have
that it's kind of like they're just
they're waiting to release it because
I've read reports that have been saying
like flash could have probably they
would have lost less money if they just
released it on streaming or not release
it at all as Warner Brothers you know
obviously around the time was also
they've inherited there's so much debt
to it and they've been on this crazy
downward spiral like of course they've
had some hits here or there but they
have overall been just a nightmare of a
situation when like a t bought them out
and then they had the whole thing during
the pandemic where they Panic released
all these films onto HBO Max same day
and day the day in theater release and
as well as on streaming and then they
pissed off a bunch of filmmakers and
talent and actors and actresses they
just pissed off a bunch of them so not
only are they having a hard time
financially rebounding their reputation
with creatives has also been tarnished
they still have some loyalty so they're
trying to do some things to bounce back
like they have uh Michael Deluca and
Pamela Abdi who have a really hot
they're very much revered for being
people who really respect talent and
artists and try to find original
filmmaking but right now Warner Brothers
they keep weren't they just in there you
might know more about this than I do
aren't they just like being reported I
saw it on Twitter at least some people
really complain about something like the
music license rights or something like
that that they're yeah they're selling
off and then also making another deal
with Netflix to hand off some more HBO
shows and stuff so they could stream it
there like they're desperate for for
money and they're just in so much debt
right now
yeah so Warner Brothers have sold half a
billion of their IP and products the um
the music licenses to a lot of films and
it just feels like David zaslav aka me
has come in and he's just selling off
scraps he's trying to pick the entire
organization clean of what he can sell
and you know shifting things over to
different Studios and just getting as
much money in the door as you can
according to the figures that were
released Warner Brothers spent 1.1
billion on marketing Shazam to the flash
Aquaman and I think Blue Beetle as well
which is absolutely insane because
they're not going to make that money
back and you're taking another loss
there you know David zazlav he loves
these bloody tax write-offs wouldn't
even release Batgirl wouldn't give that
wouldn't even dump it on streaming you
wanted all the money recouped back from
that and it's just insane how the studio
is up right now it doesn't feel like a
center for the Arts or things from the
soul it's just basically a complete
corporate mentality where it's what can
we sell how can we get any bit of money
in and what can we use as a tax
write-off I'll be surprised like if they
said we're just canceling the flash
screenings and saying that it was only a
two-week window release and we're just
getting as much tax back as we can I
wouldn't be surprised by that I think at
the moment it just feels like they're
gutting it for parts and trying to get
whatever they can out the door and it's
not the best place to start with the DCU
now Warner Brothers they've been accused
of Studio meddling in the past and a lot
of it feels like what they've like I
obviously don't know that the background
of it but I kind of feel like guns
almost being forced into this position
when he signed the contracts and he was
told look mate what we want you as the
full creative head of the brand but
you've got to also promote these films
and pretend they're part of your
universe
so yeah I kind of feel like that's gone
on and that's why James Gunn's been so
front and center with these films coming
out saying it's the greatest comic book
movie of all time why have why isn't
everyone watching it you know going to
premieres stuff like that you don't see
Matt Reeves my belt my boy Matt Reeves
you don't see him attending premieres
you know what I mean even though he's
got a DC franchise it's not
it feels like something that we don't
know about is going on behind the scenes
whether like you know you kind of have
to if you want to be the head of DC
Studios you better bloody come out and
say DC's making the greatest movies of
all time
that's another thing that I think really
worked against the movie
because I mean a big part of sales that
I've heard forever is you wanna under
promise but over deliver and you are
just way over promising at that point to
the point that after James Gunn said
that
when they had the cinema con screenings
everyone just kept going it's not like
one of the best movies ever it's not one
that became the thing which instantly
downplays uh the Flash's response and
then how people if people are interested
in it and it also kind of makes you
question some credibility with you know
again questioning the credibility of
like DC and Warner Brothers when you
over to sell something to that point uh
that and that's something I don't think
we actually really brought up last time
because not I don't not many people have
come out being like yeah it's one of the
best ones ever made
but yeah yeah to your point there is
there's so much that they're working on
the one part of it that as I did read
this Variety article from uh I think it
was on variety yeah yeah it was a
Variety article where they had Michael
Deluca and Pam Abdi as much as we can
just keep [__] on Warner Brothers
they are these two producers who they
were with MGM prior before this uh for a
little bit of time before I think Amazon
bought them everyone correct me if I'm
wrong on things I read this a couple
days ago so correct me if I'm wrong on
anything but when looking into their
history like they've produced a lot of
films that are well regarded critically
and and have also made a lot of money
and they didn't really pull that off
with MGM
but bringing them over here one thing
that they're also trying to tap into as
well and I'm sure you might have heard
about this is they're trying to get
Christopher Nolan back themselves yeah
Christopher Nolan like doing some parts
of post-production for Oppenheimer on
the Warner Brothers lot they gave him
like a seven figure bonus check and good
faith saying like no there was no like
incentive to it it was good faith when
really like they admitted they want to
get uh they want to get Christopher
Nolan back in but they also still want
to shift more of their content towards
everything they're putting out they want
to keep the focus of the next 10 years
on still a theatrical release and even
Todd Phillips who you know obviously
works with Warner Brothers of the Joker
films uh said that he saw that like
Warner Brothers like the greatest Studio
to work for and then in the past couple
years it hasn't been that at all but
then having these guys uh running the
show because you got James Gunn running
the DC students apartment these guys
running like all the other [__] you know
all the other films and to have them
here is
a lot of people might not really know
who they are like only like people who
follow film I like I wasn't even
entirely super familiar with their
filmography but looking into their track
record of things they've done I'm like
oh okay they that not only have they
done good movies but filmmakers and
talent really feel supported when
they're working with them so this could
be a step in the right direction to get
things back on track but right now in
the muck of things with Warner Brothers
it has been just a a constant battle
with people because it's like even when
the Snyder remember like it feels like
feels like a thing of history but when
you know those the people the the
championing for Snyder verse to return
that's never going to die but it's not
as loud as it once was and there was a
time where yeah that all the attacks
were against Warner Brothers so it just
seems like it's been a compounding like
the The Flash to me is the ultimate
representation or like the ultimate
metaphor for what Warner Brothers has
been over the past couple of years and
the Flash is like the ultimate byproduct
of all that yeah or it's just so much
compounding things of where you can be
like well here's what went wrong here's
what went wrong it's not you cannot say
it's this one thing for why flash failed
it's a bunch of reasons why it's failing
and same thing here is with Warner
Brothers has been just this compounding
effect and I did I didn't even really
think about how much I'd have to work to
bounce back but because like they have
Barbie coming out which I really can't
tell if it's gonna do well or not I I
haven't I'll stop you that
I I know there's a lot of hype for it I
don't think it's gonna do well and I
tell you why I lean there because men I
just I can't I don't know any men who
are gonna be like I want to go see
Barbie and I know
I'm okay well you're the first one I've
spoken to but just general normies that
I know they go down the pub oh no Friday
night you know the they eat their roast
dinner on a Sunday I go you're going to
see Barbie they look at me like I've
just uh I've just asked them a really
personal question about like do you do
you still love your wife that I'm
crossing the line with it they just sing
you are I'm not saying no Bob you know
you're crazy so obviously oppenheimer's
out the same day as well which is uh
it's not maybe not a good look for
Warner Brothers to be trying to get
Christopher Nolan back who's releasing a
film at arrival Studio on the same day
that their next big film is
um I don't know I think the plot of it
it's gonna basically hinge on that and I
think word of mouth is gonna be very
it's gonna have to win men round because
unfortunately you know For Better or
Worse women will happily go see a
male-centric film but men it went very
difficult to to get out I mean it should
change but many should be more forth
there coming with wanting to go see
female-led films but I think Barbie is
pretty much the epitome of
um a woman character almost and and men
are just I'm gonna get canceled but I'm
trying to avoid this in the best way
possible and as respectful as possible
but you know what I'm saying yeah you
shouldn't have started podcast
there's lots of uh men out there who who
might not be day one Barbie ticket
buyers especially when oppenheimer's out
the same day I mean if it comes down for
me personal preference here I'm probably
gonna go see the new Christopher Nola
movie
we should have got a woman on to argue
that point
okay
we're speaking for men and and and Men
yeah I mean obviously a lot of men would
I'm sure there's plenty of men we're
gonna get nothing but comments I'm sure
there's plenty of guys who would love to
see Barbie but I get what you're talking
about but like General audiences you
know like I'm sure there's a big portion
of men especially who are like no way
I'm not gonna watch that or my
girlfriend's gonna force me to watch it
or something like that yeah no I and
that's the interesting thing about
Barbie like I think Barbie's a
fascinating part of what Warner Brothers
is doing because when you really break
down what they're doing with Barbie I'm
not even exactly sure who this movie is
for like I really want to see it it
looks like one of those things where
it's an expensive film made by you know
an independent filmmaker and it looks
like they gave her pretty good amount of
carte blotch I would say hopefully
according to her
but you know there's like Barbie's
skewed towards little girls right that's
the who the yeah who Barbie's for but
then so much of it feels like it's adult
material at the same time so yeah and a
lot of it seems to be like a commentary
on corporations and stuff like I don't
really know who this is for
you waited at how I should have said it
Bobby is made for girls so it's not
initially that appealing to a 35 year
old man to go and see it that's how I
should have said it The Lego Movie
caught up if you're worried about
getting canceled you just said too many
words too many words this is why I
script videos normally because I can go
back and rewrite stuff whereas when I'm
just mumbling on and talking I'll come
out with some a rubbish that I'll think
the next saying think oh no I shouldn't
have said that whereas when I script it
it's fine I can record it change it
delete it but these these podcasts where
we're doing it live baby ain't no Cuts
in this
um did you take the risk man to take the
risk well then we'll get engagement when
people yell at us and say we're wrong we
talked for an hour but people will point
out you know this we'll get a bunch of
comments everyone's saying the same
thing so
I've been exposed as hating Barbie and
it's gonna destroy my reputation don't
worry but the Lego movie was a good
example where Lego is obviously marketed
to kids it's got those adult jokes in
but you could it's an animated movie
where kids can go see it and it's
totally fine I don't know if there's
gonna be that big appeal for
for young kids to go see the Barbie
movie and I feel like a lot of parents
will be apprehensive as well because it
kind of I don't I don't know if this is
right but I kind of get the feeling that
you like you said it is more geared
towards adults so I don't know if
parents will be like I don't want to
risk taking my kids to see this in case
it is you know they might drop a big a
big joke in the middle of it that I
don't really want them knowing well they
have that beach off joke you know which
obviously is a reference a sexual
reference so they had that beach off
joke did you remember that joke in the
trailer
I didn't really want I think I was
abroad no I wasn't I was on holiday I
wasn't abroad I don't know why I said
um but because you uh why I said it was
because you were having your wedding and
I'm now vicariously projecting your life
on the mind you you were having a nice
wedding weekend and I remember you
panicking because it was about the
trailer was about to come out and you
were like well my choices are recorder
reaction to the Barbie trailer or go and
get married I'm like Greg obviously you
record the reaction yeah um I did both I
don't yeah I don't think I actually
watched it well yeah there's a couple of
adult jokes yeah I watched the 2001
parody
[Music]
didn't watch and I watched bits of the
the second one and kind of just turned
it off I think
um I realized it's not for me this oh
looked in the mirror and realized
your friends all walked in and went what
are you watching the Barbie dreams so
yeah me and my my group of mates will
all be there first first showing not
satire people to for for Paul's sanity
so we don't end this video and then he's
talking to me like should I cut this out
and it's called I will I'll 100 hit you
up and go should I cut this out
it's like this is purely just a joke we
know this is not you know what my big
issue is uh when I'm nervous I'll laugh
and it makes me he seem like okay even
less he said he's laughing about not
liking Barbie get him
but yeah I'm sure
he was so not on the agenda today
and this is completely overshadowed
I just think it's so important I feel I
have that loads of people down I'm sure
people watch my channel and they thought
I bet he loves Barbie but now they know
the truth and uh unfortunately there
probably won't be a Barbie and then
explained on the channel wait do you
really not want to sign because you know
I really want I was stressing out about
it like I really want to see this movie
but do you really not want to see it
I probably will say it eventually but
it's not a day one I'm not choosing it
over Oppenheimer Nolan set off and you
kill a bomb yeah I'm going to see that
film he's he said he said some comment
in the week about how people who've
watched Oppenheimer left it very
traumatized not yet sign me up sign me
up to that yeah ruin my life it's so
long
um yeah there's a lot of long movies
coming out too we could just go on a
tangent about wire movies so goddamn my
freaking Mission Impossibles two hours
and 43 minutes and then the next week is
Oppenheimer like Jesus man these movies
are so long now flashes Indiana Jones as
well how long was that way too long
what were your thoughts on that we'll go
into a new segment Indiana Jones because
we've got them in the thumbnail yeah
what's your reaction I
um I did not really like it uh my short
version did a review you could listen to
the whole thing I actually really like
that review
um I thought I I had to edit that one
myself and I was like you know what I
like the way this one turned out this
was fun
my basic summation is this is like this
movie essentially has
three acts but but a prologue in the
beginning right so like Forex I guess
the prologue is fine young Indiana Jones
DH it's fine it's you know it's a it's
trying to capture the spirit and about
I'll admit that like I overall enjoyed
it D aging mix back give you guys like a
really short version like our review is
like 18 minutes long
version because you're explaining that
you're given the short version I'm
trying that now I'm nervous and I'm
thinking too much it's just too long
um in my head now and then act one when
you cut to Old Man Indiana Jones today I
thought it was great everything you see
on the trailer with moon day and then
like at the parade I actually I loved
all that I thought it was really
exciting and different and fresh and
then the rest of the movie uh just sort
of feels perfunctory and wrote and
really loses a lot of the spirit it
becomes like the action scenes are
really like there's a lot happening but
it's not exciting and um
the finale I could see being like I know
this I didn't even say this in a review
I know the finale is going to be
divisive because there's a moment
won't say what
where Harrison Ford is giving this
lamenting something like the most
dramatic thing you've ever seen Harrison
Ford say and do in the Indiana Jones
franchise
at half of our audience was laughing
hysterically what was going on I wasn't
I wasn't laughing but I was amused by
how half of the audience was laughing at
it
um it's going to be divisive there but
yeah I I ultimately felt because we got
this James mangled article and you sent
it to me and I I don't have this exact
section pulled up but I screenshotted it
for you where I was like this is exactly
what my problem with this movie was
was that James Mangold if you it's what
I said about Guardians of the Galaxy
whoever takes over that franchise
whenever they do a new Guardians if you
try to do what James Gunn did you will
fail bottom line you're just gonna look
like you're trying to be James Gunn and
that word shrine will be very much
underscored and mangled in this variety
interview he practic he does admit like
I just I'm trying to just do what Steven
Spielberg did it's pretty much the whole
time and the first Act of that movie on
moon day because that's so much divorce
from what's typical Indiana Jones is
when James mangled's really doing his
own thing way more and so I really
enjoyed it and it's got this breath of
fresh air there's confidence and then
and then act two like most of the movie
is like a a lack of like Steven
Spielberg couldn't even do Steven
Spielberg for Kingdom of the Crystal
Skull so why would you try to do Steven
Spielberg but he couldn't even replicate
being Steven Spielberg uh so yeah like
it it was it just lacked a lot of energy
and and fun and it was a little bit it
was boring I was I was actually pretty
bored like I I actually like the finale
um but it wasn't enough to save most of
the experience that I felt with vast
majority of the film because the movie
is forever it's a very very long movie
so you know what I think the issue is as
well with even Steven Spielberg can't do
old ski Steven Spielberg now Steven
Spielberg a lot of those techniques they
used are dead now it's just all very CGI
heavy swinging through the The Vines and
stuff like that I watched Terminator 2
today for a breakdown I could not
believe how much you know how good
practical stuff looks if you go back to
those Indiana Jones movies a lot of them
are kind of they're done on a shoestring
budget all practical obviously except
for the ghosts coming in
um but a lot of those things if you did
it now the studio would be like we need
some CGI we needed to be shut on blue
screen the entire thing and they
wouldn't have done it back in the day
and those are all dead techniques now so
you just don't get the feeling you can
replicate it to a certain amount but
eventually it'll just feel sort of like
a modern movie where it feels kind of
fake and all it was the same thing with
the Star Wars films where you know you
watch the force awakens it it's sort of
leaning towards being a one of those
original movies but it it's just
something off about it where it feels
more like a and film instead of an
actual Star Wars film and I've I also
worry about James Mangold I think he's
gonna get hit with the Star Wars
director's curse which I'm just coining
this right now
so I've noticed recently yeah a lot of
the time when Kathleen Kennedy and
lucasfilm grab a director it's when
they're in their Prime it's they're the
hot new director get him so Ryan Johnson
got announced a Trilogy D and D you know
they got that we got told they were
making a Star Wars movie
um thought about that yeah taika with TT
Josh trank Lord
solo yeah yeah exactly they grabbed them
the hot thing with the hammer bring the
Star Wars Trilogy James Van gold
obviously as well and then they that
director does their next project and
this is definitely the case in taika
with TD I feel like Ryan Johnson's kind
of came back but you know that project
isn't well received and then lucasfilmer
kind of stuck with this director who was
the hot new thing and all of a sudden
there's this backlash against them and I
I do worry that James Mangold might get
it as well he's came out he's said
something very stupid about Logan
um and appearing in Deadpool 3 saying
that I'll try and get the cut up the
exactly that's the one thing I saved for
this podcast well you have it right here
Craig yeah that's correct cut to Greg
um he said I can't say there's a part of
me that doesn't wish that we'd let it be
but there was always going to be another
Wolverine there could be a baby
Wolverine and a cartoon Wolverine and as
much liquid as they can squeeze out of
that rag they're going to try to I don't
measure my success on a movie like Logan
with whether we ended the conversation I
ended my conversation
just kind of crazy coming from the guy
who just made Indiana Jones I mean yeah
is that freaking Disney's gonna try to
squeeze as much as they can out of that
Wolverine and I'm like you you just made
Indiana Jones that's where you're
promoting in this interview right now
and he's making a call
the coal is coming from inside the house
James
um Indiana the Last Crusade yeah they
made a movie called The Last Crusade the
Last Crusade that was gonna be the final
film they made that movie and you're
still squeezing stuff from the rag so
when when he's saying stuff like that I
mean he just it just sets him up to get
dunked on really doesn't it yeah um and
I feel like the audience is gonna start
to turn against them slightly if this
bombs it's going to cause a lot of
issues potentially at lucasfilm Kathleen
Kennedy I mean the guy could become
another Ryan Johnson I like Ryan Johnson
but the amount of crap and bad feelings
people have online towards him because
of the Last Jedi it's it's rare I go on
Twitter and someone's not talking about
Ryan Johnson messing up the Last Jedi
unfortunately I think the guy's fully
redeemed himself in my eyes and I I
don't think he was the problem with that
film looking at it I think you know he's
made enough good movies where you can
say this guy's talented I feel that's
the same with James Mangold
I'm gonna see uh first thing Wednesday
morning nine nine a.m I've got my
tickets booked for Indy 9am I'm gonna
watch this at nine in the morning
yeah it's gonna be a great way to start
the day thanks for getting me excited
for a Greg he really sold it so yeah
your expectations are so goddamn low
that you're like everyone's wrong
it's going up and I think audiences are
gonna enjoy it way more than
I don't know man it's kind of boring
it's kind of a boring film it's just
yeah it was a little slow I think James
mangle will be fine because unlike Ryan
Johnson who didn't have as much of a
reputation you know like he like James
Michael's had such a filmography for for
years now you know and it's only just
been going up up and and yeah I've had
that same concern too where like it just
takes that one movie to ruin you I feel
like he's if his next movie after this
is terrible is bad or something because
because I wouldn't say this movie is
terrible it's just a little boring if
that makes sense like it's not
offensively bad it's just a little
boring it's a little forgettable
um the the but if his next leg is he
really is really hyping up his Swamp
Thing movie and like I like like have
you seen his movie Identity oh that
would be such a good breakdown Paul have
you seen identity
no I don't think I have oh you would
love that oh my God it would be a
perfect breakdown heavy spoilers fans
pressure Paul into doing a I can't
believe you haven't seen that movie I
think you would really love that film it
is I must have Twisty the one in the
motel and John Cusack and James mangle
made it it's got a lot of like these
horror motifs throughout it's like a
psychological horror movie
um no 2003 no I was drinking heavily
back then I was about 14 years old I
think uh you'd have a blast with that
okay anyway yeah like but that was like
I think my first James mangle film I
ever saw before I realized because this
guy has such a that was one of the
disappointing Parts is he's got such a
variety of styles and he knows how to
hone in on genres so well that I'm I was
missing that uh from him here
in front of me it is it sounds very
hypocritical like because yeah lastly
I'll I'll drop the subject here on it
but like the last thing I'll say is that
when I know that when you say this movie
doesn't feel necessary there's always
someone who's like well why movies
necessary why does people say that I
hate that
the Last Crusade a part of why that was
made was in response to the reaction
from Temple of Doom even though Temple
of Doom is is like like the like loved
by so many people now it was a response
to make up for like Steven Spielberg has
has said that that he wanted to do it to
make up for it so there was a
necessitation to providing that film and
it shows many people that's their
favorite one
um I'm subjectively speaking of course
for me that's my favorite Indiana Jones
movie
and then
and then this does not feel necessary it
doesn't feel like a swan song by the end
of it all it really like I I had that
was one of my first thoughts and I was
like this really felt like an
unnecessary film like we didn't need to
make this and it's I don't usually say
this is an unnecessary film however for
this one I was like this this really
felt unnecessary it doesn't feel like it
makes up for Kingdom of the Crystal
Skull or something like that it really
didn't need to be made so for for him to
come in here I'm like nah man you just
wanted to make your like I love so many
of your films but it really seems like
you you wanted to just you know make an
Indiana Jones movie because you love
Indiana Jones but you're this thing
you're criticizing for what they did
with granted Wolverine died so there's a
difference there that is a massive
difference just spoiled the end and I
thought Indiana Jones might die mate no
no I'm saying I thought James Mangold
was gonna make Logan green died
okay okay I don't want people that I
would never spoil something like that
they're made they announced Indiana
Jones six by the end of this guys
okay great
um yeah like I said uh
I'm like I don't even if I say he dies
this is what if I say he doesn't die
it's a spoiler which way do I go with
this to reply here
yeah I I mean I I think a lot of people
are excited to see James Mangold after
after Logan you know doing that final
Indiana Jones story and thinking it was
gonna be you know this franchise's
answer to Logan
doesn't sound like it is unfortunately
but hey man we should talk about uh
Jonathan majors
transition yeah
now first off we we've been laughing and
joking but I think this is quite a
serious subject I mean just come in now
we we have talked about how we're going
to handle this
um before we we speak about it and
I think we just need to avoid speaking
about the allegations and there is a lot
honestly there's a lot of back and forth
and you know I I I'm seeing a lot of
things that really make me question
everything that we've been told I
haven't actually publicly said what what
I think and I've just I haven't even
made up my own mind to be honest I think
I I always want to wait and see until
the full stories out there and this is
obviously something that people are
going to come into with a lot of baggage
because everyone's got their own
personal feelings towards it you know
those people who think that he's being
set up there's people who think that
he's gonna get away with it there's
people who think that he he hasn't done
it is you know what I mean there's so
many different things there's people who
just
want to see Marvel movies and stuff like
that and it's just such it it is very
difficult to cover these things with a
lot of respect and their sensitive
subjects as well so we don't want to
Wade in and you know it's not we're not
going to have the same approach that we
did on the barbie subject
um so
we're gonna try and stick to what we
think could happen and unfortunately
I've been looking through a lot of
things coming up and I just don't know
how Marvel can handle this to be honest
because the the thing with Jonathan
Majors is they've built so much of the
upcoming phase around him and obviously
they've delayed a lot of things as well
and it's going to be if this is an
ongoing trial how are they gonna film
those projects alongside it you know
what I mean it's going to be so
difficult to be like kangs of filming
this movie
um whilst during the majors is having to
go and attend court for this heinous
thing and it's looking at it
I really don't know how they're gonna
handle it and it's it's crazy like
because it's so built around him it's
not if it was like a bit part I think
they could get away with just recasting
him
um but looking at this they've obviously
built the entire thing around him and
there could be so much controversy
coming out now there was a tick tock
video released recently that kind of
debunked a lot of the things that the
claimant said but again it's like do you
take the word of a tick tocker you know
what I mean so there's so much
it's such a crazy situation and very
difficult to kind of Wade through right
so what do you think Marvel will end up
doing bear in mind they they have
delayed things to be fair Kang Dynasty's
coming out I think 2026 or 24 what are
the ads but Secret Wars is coming out
2027 so they've got four years now
between that like now when the trials
started till to then yeah
but how many how many projects is kind
gonna be in up until that point
I mean they're still releasing low-key
season two right and uh but that's in
the can that's filmed I mean it was the
same thing with Ezra Miller where
they filmed it all it was ready so that
was what they were saying that's like it
was too difficult
yeah it's too difficult to go back and
re-film the Flash with a different actor
because they've obviously shot scenes
twice with Ezra Miller and with Kang
being a multiversal character I'm
guessing that there's scenes where he
and I mean the end of quantum Mania
we've got several different kangs
interacting with each other
um not to the level that they were in
The Flash but there was still a lot
going on there well you know without
yeah without diving too much into the
allegations what I'll what I'd say is
that
because of for people who don't know if
they really wanna find out what a lot
where a lot of the information I'm
surprised in all honesty I'm a little
bit surprised that none of this is
becoming as uh you know popular in the
Zeitgeist as of course yeah it makes
sense like I was being surprised not
surprised of the wrong word wrong choice
of words here
the the bit you can go to Insider and
then that's where it breaks it down
where the lawyer pretty much unveiled a
lot of what they have and then a lot of
what they what they have in support of
Jonathan Majors for the incident that he
is um you know defending himself against
uh with his ex-girlfriend there seems
like according to the defense and in the
mountains of like testimony and footage
and all these other things pictures body
cam footage there's a lot
there's a lot in his in his side that
seems to support that he could be
innocent and granted that's just the
defensive side so you know we have to
that's why there's going to be a trial
we have to see it plays out what the
prosecution is going to be presenting
and then we've heard about other other
people who want to come forward where
he's he's focused on proving his case
here with this one the one incident he
got arrested for right like that's where
he has to prove his innocence and I
think overall
it's gonna sound strange to say it's
happening at the best time for him like
this he shouldn't be he's not God if
he's innocent like if he is indeed
innocent should be it sucks that's
happening at all for him the fact that
he has to fight this it's happening at a
fine time for him
because huh
I think I know what you mean but
and they have the SAG strike which is
more than I mean it hasn't been like at
the time filming this we have till June
30th to find out it looks like the SAG
strike is going to happen where like
everything's gonna shut down with
filming like everything's gonna shut
down like Marvel's not even going to uh
Comic-Con most studios are not going to
Comic-Con now most pulled out because we
have these strikes happening here so in
return in return in regards to Jonathan
Majors he has time to settle this and
solve this and
in all honesty like the if he is indeed
innocent the way he's going about it is
one of the smartest ways he can do it
because he's not doing interviews he's
not putting himself out there to
strongly associate you know his his
whole image with this it's like but he
at the same time he knows he has to
clear his name so if he has the
opportunity to clear his name then
excellent do it the way of the trial the
way how like Johnny Depp was able to
clear his name via the way of the trial
like that that's the smartest way to do
it especially if he's able to
legitimately prove that he is indeed
innocent go that way that way I mean
there'll always be people if he's proved
innocent who will you know make up their
mind he's guilty however it's like
nothing will speak stronger than the
court deeming you innocent after all
this evidence and stuff right so he has
the time to prove his innocence the way
he's going about her to smart and I
think Marvel also doesn't want another
James Gunn firing situation on their
hand where they fire Jonathan Majors uh
before this plays out and and then if
he's you know deemed innocent in the
court of law then everyone's going to be
like oh Disney Marvel why'd you do like
and they're just going to get the same
they're gonna get James Gunn situation
again so yeah and they're playing it the
smartest way if everything was still
like filming and they had to keep it
going then I'd be like they're probably
gonna have to let Jonathan Majors go
um but if they have these delays because
I believe his court trial I believe it
starts happening in August
and I imagine the strikes within all
that will still be out here we he's
gonna there's plenty of delays now for
him to to buy him some time to prove his
innocence basically because I don't feel
like I mean like what was the Johnny
Depp one that was like what uh six weeks
something like that yeah I think we
started in May last year and then yeah
kind of I don't feel like this would go
on as long as that and this is supposed
to start in August yeah I mean from what
I've seen of the counter evidence he has
a very strong case but then when I've
spoken privately with people about this
they've said well why hasn't the D.A
just thrown out the K so why hasn't the
judges thrown out the case and it's kind
of like oh well I don't know and that's
kind of why I don't like speaking on
allegations and stuff like that because
you just don't know you know we went
there we haven't had the evidence as
well and a lot of people are judging
before they know the full story
um I think obviously you have to take
these allegations seriously as well and
it's such a bad situation but you know
like you said you might be right you
know
it's happening at a time where they have
time to at least get the verdict out
before things go into production and
obviously with the movies being pushed
back several years starring him
it is kind of you know saying it's the
best time for him to happen is a weird
way to phrase it which is why you
shouldn't have said it Greg but I
understand what you're saying he he has
opportunity here and at least the
timing's not as bad as it could have
been that's what he should have said the
timing could have been a lot worse yeah
we haven't been canceled we're learning
how to phrase things in real yeah
honestly like that's the thing when
you're speaking on these things you just
overthink everything you're saying
because no matter what we say someone's
gonna get angry somewhere like I I said
something about Wonder Woman 84 having a
good third act and it was we what yeah
yeah I'll kill you so when it's more
sensitive like this it's even more
difficult
um but My worry is as well and I spoke
about this on Twitter the other day this
is just more industry things we're not
talking about allegations and stuff yet
sure but by the time secret was and it's
kind of building off the back of the
flash as well but by the time Secret
Wars comes out in 2027 are people gonna
be tired of the whole Multiverse thing
now Deadpool 3 there was a it's not um
not good transition I see it wasn't an
announcement yeah I'm slick like that it
wasn't
it wasn't an announcement but there was
a report saying that Ben Affleck had
been spotted on the set of Deadpool 3
and that he was going to be reprising
his role as Daredevil you know the
original Maddie Murdoch watched the
extended edition version of Daredevil
it's got Coolio in it completely cut
from the main film but I tell you what
that extended edition makes that film
way way better it's really good
so
the response you would have thought
would have been Ben Affleck's back and
another superhero movie coming back is a
character that he said he wasn't gonna
play where have I heard that before
um but it's kind of been a lukewarm
reception and I'm starting to think are
people gonna be still hungry for
Multiverse stories come 2027. now I
think Secret Wars has the potential to
be the end game of Multiverse movies
I've been rereading Jonathan Hickman's
run if you haven't read it everything
building up to Secret Wars is absolutely
incredible I'll I'll not chew your ear
off with it but been going back through
it and if they can adapt this it's going
to be the best Multiverse Story by far
but will people even care Greg I turn it
over to you
it's weird you asked me that if you ask
me this when Secret Wars was announced
even with the delay I'd be like of
course man it's Secret Wars
I am there with I I feel that concern
though now
because even as someone who loves all
this [__] I'm still going oh I'm already
starting to get a little tired of the
multiver like I'm already I'm already a
little tired of it because it's not just
marvel that's doing it you know like
everyone's doing the Multiverse now and
by that point if they haven't mastered
how to truly sell consequences and
personal Stakes
within your big comic book movies when
it comes to the Multiverse if they
haven't really because it kind of feels
like a lot of it just sort of boils down
to this you know something's colliding
in that there's some Collision of [__]
happening with universes you know fill
in the blank with some science mumbo
jumbo and then boom that's what's
happening
that becomes repent it's the same thing
how we got sick of like Sky beams you
know you start to you start to need
something real personal to latch onto
and I think everything ever well at once
was like this it doesn't help that an
independent movie it became the standard
for how to do and how to excel at like a
masterpiece of a Multiverse movie to
make it crazy Hog Wild at the same time
to make it feel like truly personal and
emotional and these concrete movies
often don't do like across the spider
versus been the best that come at like
getting there right
and by the time we get to Seeker Wars
I think we might there is a bit of that
concern man uh I feel like we might feel
a little I think everyone will still
tune in I think it just depends on the
trailer and everyone who's in it and
it's like how well have they gotten us
to get to know the Multiverse of the
characters by that point more than them
just showing up and being like Hey look
it's an alternate version of a character
we know and there's a famous person
there I think we need they need to be
real characters by the time we get to
Secret Wars is like the main thing you
just gotta get down because if it's just
Cameo Fest it's not going to cut it I
think Deadpool 3 would like that that
could be really fun because there's this
whole Fox Universe associated with it so
they could do that whole Deadpool guy
because I don't know I feel like when it
comes to the problem with Multiverse too
is people often like over hype
themselves you know with like yeah the
matter craziness that they could get
it's called a Multiverse so you think
like this should be like I know my home
was crazy man they're gonna do so many
crazy things and no way home is a great
example of like when he this Spider-Man
movies did a good job with Multiverse
overall but the but by that point when
you gotta move like that huge
I don't know like I like Multiverse and
Madness but I wasn't like Blown Away by
the Illuminati as most people weren't it
was like fun to see them for a second so
yeah it's like whatever the Multiverse
ends up being by that point we just need
to have actual investment in whoever
these other characters are because if
it's just a big introduction of like
look alternate Wolverine alternate Iron
Man alternate like if it just gets to
that point where that's the movie it'll
it's like okay it's cool at first but
not really that ex like the excitement
Factor weighs off pretty quick uh
quicker than I think a lot of us
anticipated it would
I think the Hollywood's learned the
wrong lesson from Multiverse movies and
it's just becoming Cameo Fest it's like
what actor can we get back what what who
can we get in when that's not really the
case now you were talking about
incursions before in World smashing
together and how that doesn't feel like
it has consequences I'll tell you why it
does Greg and this is what they do
perfectly Wars run
the the know the peop the the reason
that you feel this stuff is because the
heroes who are destroying the worlds or
people that you like and they hit a
point you know they get lucky on the
first couple of incursions where there's
you know the first one they they managed
to push it away by using The Infinity
Gauntlet and and that sends the the
world spiraling back and the Illuminati
is like oh well we've destroyed The
Infinity Gauntlet trying to do that
we're not going to get another chance at
it and they're like what should we do
like we're gonna have to destroy worlds
from now on we're gonna have to actually
kill people in Captain America is like
I'm not doing that uh join the
Illuminati to save people and uh
whatever it takes I'll make sure that
that we don't sacrifice any lives and
what Tony and Doctor Strange do is to
just go right well erase his memory he
can't remember anything that's happened
they erased Steve Rogers memory he wakes
up and there's there's the Avengers run
so there's the new Avengers book and the
The Avengers book The Avengers book is
about Steve such as not remembering
anything and just singing everything's
fine and just doing really cookie cutter
adventures and the new Avengers book is
about the Illuminati in the background
going around destroying worlds killing
trillions of people and having to deal
with the cost that comes with that and
acting normal like everything's okay
like oh you look really stressed today
Tony what's the matter he's like oh
nothing
um and they get given this eight hour
timeline
and they basically have to figure out in
that amount of time what the hell
they're gonna do do they let their will
get destroyed and so on and so forth
some worlds they'll travel to it and
Galactus will already be destroying that
world because
um if you destroy the world in that
Universe it stops the incursion and
because that's the main incursion Point
some universes they'll go over and like
versions of the Justice League will show
up and they'll be like we'll we'll sort
this out and we'll try and be we'll try
and come to a peaceful resolution and it
just devolves into them fighting each
other to the death Doctor Strange sells
his soul so he can get more power to
destroy these worlds and there's so much
cost that comes with it to the point
where the heroes themselves are just
completely defeated by what they're
having to do and they're basically
carrying out the murder of billions
every couple of days and what does that
cost a hero now will Disney do that
um no but they did sort of touch upon it
with the Illuminati destroying Doctor
Strange to stop incursions and stuff so
I I am hoping they do sort of go that
way with it but uh if they do I don't
know I think Hollywood's gonna basically
go don't don't worry about what it costs
their soul have you seen Ben Affleck's
back he's wearing his Daredevil costume
like okay yeah yeah so yeah
like that is great like where you they
Infinity I read The Infinity Gauntlet uh
comic and I I think like the infinity
war and end game story is a is a really
cool
it's like it's certainly not a
one-to-one you know uh yeah bringing
some difficult but they take elements
for sure that are like a strong
adaptation and I think there's a way to
make that work but you know the lead up
to it they had a really strong focus on
your films outside of the Avengers uh
you know Unity films and I think that
they need a really good that ship in
order before me yeah we do the secret
War stuff because
yeah I mean like when I think of
Multiverse of Madness
the real threat is Wanda right and not
really like the incursion things
happening I'm not really concerned about
that I'm really like Wanda and then uh
even in The Flash movie you know they
had the this is not it's I know it's not
Marvel but at the very end they're like
the universe is respected together like
I don't yeah I didn't know this was part
of what's happening in this movie but
but okay this is this is now a thing
because that's what happens in all the
Multiverse things so yeah if every
Multiverse movie has that quality that
threat becomes diluted so yeah it's like
that's why getting a strong handle and
bottom line is I know a lot of people
really thought Jonathan Majors did a
great job and I thought he did a great
job in quantumania as well
I'm sorry
but the best scenes in that film are him
oh that one with him and Michelle
Pfeiffer crazy undoubtedly best scenes
at the same time there were a lot of
people who even liked Jonathan majors in
it who didn't like the handling of how
Kang ultimately was defeated in that
movie you know so if you keep having
that effect and if Kane keeps getting
showing up and getting killed off in
some way even it could be Loki season
two you know we've seen two kings get
you know lose already or die already not
really he who remains he kind of want he
wanted that to happen so that's
different he was still like in control
even though he died but uh but if we get
other whatever Kings we get moving
forward you know we need
yeah this is really important to get the
job the major [__] in order because we
need that Central threat like at the end
of the day Infinity war and all that
like yeah we're dealing with half the
universe being wiped out but that's not
what you're really fearing what you're
really fearing is Thanos and we need
that as well for Secret Wars that you
can have your cool Multiverse backdrop
but what's really going to matter most
is the the actual
physical antagonist who's walking around
threatening Our Heroes it could be
Doctor Doom could be you know it should
be yeah
obviously the the villain of Secret Wars
the heroes find out that he actually
caused the incursion so there's
basically this central figure called
molecule man who exists the same in
every single universe and he was built
by the beyonders to basically be a bomb
in every single Universe and Dr Doom
finds us out and he goes through every
single reality and kills every version
of molecule man and and he's basically
trying to wipe out a a virus in the
background before destroys the entire
Multiverse however in doing this it
accidentally starts knocking Earths into
each other and that's when the incursion
comes from and so like I don't know 300
issues long it's a lot to talk about but
it's surprised to be two movies don't
you I feel like secret warships
really surprised me that um Doom's not
connected to this at all because the
rumors were that he was going to show up
at the end of wakanda forever and then
didn't and I was like but the secret was
it would be like having
Infinity War but you have
think of a Marvel and film quickly you
have Dr Doom instead of Thanos you know
that didn't really make sense
um so we'll see what happens
but so far
I I just look at the I honestly look at
the phase five slate and think
how is this building to Secret Wars
because all of these you know armor Wars
how is that going to build to Secret
Wars because it's very low-key and
grounded stuff
um
I think Fantastic Four can probably do
it but Thunderbolts stuff like that
Captain America New World Order I'm not
really seeing the the seeds being
planted here for Secret Wars we will see
though but just from what I know of the
story
I don't know so yeah is there any more
topics to cover
I think we covered all them I think
we're on track I think we we did a good
job today
and I think yeah I actually feel very
happy with this and that means that
we're gonna get nothing but down boats
and I'm gonna get a message from Paul
tomorrow
yeah
so yeah thanks for joining us again guys
obviously if you're watching us on
YouTube and you want to listen to us on
the go you can go to Spotify
um Apple podcasts
Amazon podcasts across the spoilerverse
where they're we're there for you guys
wherever whenever you want to listen to
us we'll be there and yeah and we'll try
to make this thing you know a friendly
sort of just sitting around chatting
about stuff having a laugh it's not a
completely restrictive podcast where
it's like you have to stick to the topic
and you've got 10 minutes want this to
be more conversational and we we hope
you guys join in the on the conversation
too so yeah drop a comment below let us
know your thoughts you disagree
um I was thinking doing some stuff next
week where we pick some comments to read
them out so if you've got any questions
that you think we'll have we'll have a
quick scroll through and steal steal
your ideas and say they're ours so uh
yeah thanks a lot guys go shop zero
edition.com as well if you've enjoyed
the merch I'm wearing you don't have to
wear it you just if you if you just want
to buy it and that helps me out I
appreciate that
sweater today uh everything I wears me
underneath now with shop Zero edition
underneath my meundies that's what I do
why is it on top of it if it's your
undies
uh uh yeah you know I should have
prepared for this one yeah
they just have sweaters balls that's
pretty straight I think this counts yeah
I think this counts as a meundy's brand
deal and I'll be invoicing the company
right in the next 10 minutes asking
where the money is there is four Brands
I would work with all the time me undies
G Fuel manscaped and athletic greens
throw the four all right well we're not
actually advertising for them Jesus I
just I'm just trying to put it out there
right now I just want to get it out
there we're having that single brand
deal on this podcast yet that's all I'm
hoping
that's why we appreciate we appreciate
you guys supporting liking the videos
and stuff in there yeah I hope you enjoy
the rest of your week we'll be back for
the next one to talk about whatever
whatever the hell is going on and you
know what I promise it'll be our best
episode ever you know you got that heavy
spoilers promise baby so I'll see you
next time thanks a lot Greg for sticking
with me
you take care guys peace cheers